a vida das pessoas
achamos nós é um segmento reta e exames
que vamos do ponto a ao ponto b
às vezes no percurso vida dessas pessoas
ao momento que altera certa forma esse
percurso e eu não sei se é assim eu a
conheci uma senhora chamada manuela
mulher com os corintianos
chegou ao meu trabalho por intermédio do
amigo estima que por eu e houve naquele
ambiente um pouco informar o qual é o
problema em que eu poderia ajudar
manuela que chapas que se sentia
observada quando estava a usar o
computador
eu confesso que fui um pouco conforme
ela dizendo essas coisas sempre
observada não sente à vontade
o computador às vezes ficava muito lento
e complicado
os amigos diziam que ela estava online
no facebook quando estava na altura ver
wifi vídeo não é o futebol me five a
câmara acendia e apagava e um diâmetro
ela deu é que o seu e mel
era o que eu queria fazer o computador
problema risco a vida dela
os dias depois aparecem no meu trabalho
três homens num deus é a marisa manuela
e é auto raja que vivia me engano
computador é meu não é da minha mulher
não há necessidade
por favor o que fez
irmã e alguns amigos eu acho que se não
estivesse no local trabalho com os meus
colegas de trabalho eu provavelmente
teria tentado matar muito agradável
depois é manuela chega ao local trabalho
que eu faço muito marcada e computador e
trazia um presidente que não era
cumprido ela suplicou que ele voltasse a
colocar o computador precisa mesmo como
eu estava
sentou-se na sessão ficou uma hora
impacientemente a minha vida o
computador dela
acho que na semana seguinte
eu recebo a visita da pj a colocar
questões sobre pesquisa manuela e
disseram que manuela tenha sido
assassinada que o seu meio tempo sentado
uma conversa com uma casa abrigo em um
ato insano matou a vítima
até hoje sinto um certo
desde então aqui vai o foco do estudo é
que o faz trabalhar diariamente e é um
menino e uma menina que o princípio os
dias e olho para a segurança informática
que o olho naquela altura dessa maneira
eu vi em uma componente que segurança
informática ou a falta dela em última
instância pode causar a custar a vida
uma pessoa
desde então eu faço profissionalmente é
e tenha que sair pra mim é um enigma e
cobra província quanto nós consideram a
segurança informática enigma aquela
coisa chata é que eu tenho que ser o que
o antivírus firewall é que é uma coisa
que vai custar dinheiro todos os anos
temos que estar atentos funciona o que a
interpretação quem é que tem telemóvel
encriptado para que serve
ouvimos a vias na televisão que andava
havia uma dificuldade com o fórum é
creditado
ora será que isso é uma questão cultural
se a questão é uma questão só acontece
aos outros podem indivíduo empatar a
vida de muita gente
eu acho que sim acho que eu tenho
certeza é cultural ea controlar porque
as pessoas preferem transparência
as pessoas não querem saber como
funcionam os sistemas gostam do
resultado gostam de se ver como é que o
resultado final vai ficar mas não querem
saber quem está por trás como é que esse
programa como é que nesse programa o que
é o bicho que ela vai ter isso não
importa para nada
as pessoas gostam desta transferência é
ele pois isso de certa forma impacta a
vida muita gente
cultural uma das maiores empresas deste
país há muito pouco tempo atrás o
enxofre para uma rede social na
fotografia dos seus sistemas de
informação
tudo estava lá muito bonito 500
servidores dos sistemas de confiança e
afecto e para quem estava posto e pensa
mesmo uma questão econômica ele é pai
não sabe nada daquilo mas agora vejo que
ela ia ganhar coisas interessantes
projectos
essa é uma questão cultural não somos só
nós é o nosso ego é forma que nós
entrarmos nas organizações e podemos até
certa forma pensar assim
todos nós já temos facebook e de quem
fez ou quem sabe até os posts aquelas
publicações que ele não imagina o que
estamos é fácil quando há que convir que
o homem então esse cãozinho como é que
está o que nós fazemos juro que é o
facebook importados para uma página
maliciosa fração de segundos ler todo o
nosso coisas negras com filhos
os dados servem para mais tarde seria
enviar uma lista existem bancos janela
do código do cliente que preenche
automaticamente essas informações
valiosas sabem que ganhamos mil horas no
meio do ano e que temos certa forma
contribuir para que ninguém é nisto ou
muito poucas pessoas
alguns meios bancários são muito
perfeito
o imel sempre uma chamada você moto mata
e christian klien o seu cartão foi usava
indevidamente do 500
por questões de segurança para poder
desbloquear em todos os três dias de
segurança só na parte de trás do seu
cartão usando o teclado por fora isso
existe
podemos dizer que quem está nessas
organizações olha para nós e não nos vê
dentro de nós dentro das necessidades do
dinheiro à segurança o cartão de
multibanco que agora está muito mal aqui
o cartão sem fios os carros não precisa
ser introduzido dentro das máquinas de
pagamento
a maior parte dos deputados é possível
que uma simples aplicação android por
ser o nome avalizado o banco emitiu e
ontem vi um caso quantas o processo
feitas naquele dia que eu quero ficar e
essa informação está em está aqui pra
qualquer pessoa usar para depois entrar
nos meandros do é pra poder ser vendido
em última instância está tudo vendido
por pessoas não querem uma ligação
direta com um movimento dinheiro extra
que só acontece aos outros
eu tenho uma mãe muito popular ela
escreve e tem 5 mil 6 mil amigos no
facebook e um dia de 2014 seja muita
gente do facebook chamada trazia toda a
minha faca e fez uma limpeza quando os
três mil e china ao tráfego que é o
segmento que o chefe que eu vou limpar
três mil pessoas no facebook e minha mãe
um dia foi o meu facebook foi ficar na
fotografia da maria clara que minha
filha tem um ano e meio e colocou no
facebook ela dorme no parque da cidade
estou ansiosa por próximo final de
semana
a vovó facebook permitem fazer uma coisa
chamada rivers
acham que alguém vai escalar aquela cara
aquelas casa chegando no sentido
contrário a informação até nós e criar
também última instância uma hipótese de
cruzar fisicamente a vida a deus a nossa
será que daquelas pessoas que estão no
facebook a mãe deixa eu dizer que o
tempo umbundu partilhas laicos foi
fantástico para mim eu sei que o ego dos
pintos
mas eu senti do meu lado uma questão que
praticar crimes lógico que aquele
sotaque que era quem é que agora sabe
que minha mãe porque ela está um pouco
lento o sentimento vai ao parque da
cidade
minha filha sozinha todos os tempos fez
o que temos amigos 100 200 300 mais
extrovertidos mil ea pergunta que eu
deixe ficar aqui é flor falta é das
pessoas que estão no vosso pessoa
quantas delas durante uma hora sem
qualquer vigilância nossa parte conferir
um filho voz durante o que acontece
quando estamos há demasiado informação
que possa indicar os nossos hábitos
isso aqui vai virar a página digital e
poderá então uma pessoa impactar a vida
de muita gente
há um tempo atrás do caso do médio isso
o mec lançou para o web milhares e
milhares e milhares de dados das
relações extra-conjugais maridos
e não foi só esse tipo de informação que
lançaram foi o número de vezes que
fizeram com quem o fizeram eu seja um
menino ainda qual será o meu lado e essa
informação em dúvida muita gente não
foram só 250 mil foram os possíveis
os filhos o estigma nas escolas
e o resultado foi suicídio vários
suicídios chefe de polícia jeff primeiro
o maior nos matarão desporto
alguém decidiu que eu era a forma certa
de enviar para o ego um alerta do que eu
saiba não é puro e muitos piratas
informáticos e muitos é que as pessoas
sentem que é passar esta informação que
o facto desta manhã estão de facto a
contribuir para a sociedade
o caso do panamá papers está uma coisa
um pouco duvidosa agora não é novidade
para quem anda já depois de alguns anos
temos o programa peppers a ua uma
consciência de quem anda à volta deste
assunto foi uma exploração de uma vpn
alguém por uma vpn conseguiu entrar no
sistema conseguiu entrar na rede
informática e processamento no serviço
de mel eo resultado está à vista caírem
governos a especulação a paranóia ao
produto interno bruto um dos países aqui
isto porque alguém eu vejo sempre a
mensagem que o neca faz por prestígio
o pirata informático fazer estas coisas
toda uma questão de dinheiro
o craque faz por causa do medo por
tentativa de destruir criar confusão
nós somos meu no ano passado em portugal
foram constituídos arguidos
mil e quinhentas pessoas programa
informático que estas aulas em diante o
crime informático causa um doou vimento
sucesso
e é o que posso fazer
qual é a mensagem havia senhor uma
chance a notícia que eu acho fantástica
que foi não perceber ao certo quem é
quem vem thomas sírios criar um
movimento na cabeça dos nossos filhos e
claro uma porção de que vemos por dentro
de uma mochila uma série de ritmos e
depois colocarmos na posição não fugir a
pé até um caso em foco agora mas esta
geração vai ser um dia vai dar frutos e
vai dar frutos instruídos e cultos e
quando um dia de prêmios que não haja
uma vaga de imigrantes e refugiados
eu consigo perceber criar um empate
então o que eu acho que temos que fazer
é puxar pra nós é decisão e criar uma
necessidade de segurança informática
dizendo que o comprou computador e usa
época eu vou gastar dinheiro com a
empresa mas eu quero estar dentro do
meio precisa eu quero estar dentro do
processo clichy e eu sinto segura assim
e não ser apenas um momento que é
chamada a pagar
então vamos dentro das nossas gerações
de criar aqui vou dar lhe uma pequena
semente para que nos próximos anos o uso
da tecnologia dos grandes dados da nuvem
do frigorífico fazer compras por nós
tudo isso seja automático mas sem
colocar em causa o futuro das próximas
gerações